gary payton ii almost interviewed to  become a video coordinator for the  warriors after he got cut from the  roster before the 2021 and 2022 season  tayden had always bounced around the nba  and g-league so hearing he wasn't making  the roster wasn't that crazy but to him  it was better to be around the team than  not at all so working for the team  seemed to be the next best thing his  decision to hang around paid off because  a couple days later he was called in  they said how they see him they see how  dedicated he is and that he made the  team peyton went on to become a crucial  part of the warriors lineup and he just  signed a three-year 28 million dollar  deal with the trailblazers